[Music]
hi guys it's me quinn and as always if
you appreciate my content consider
hitting the like button it's the only
way the youtube algorithm really notices
me
imagine you're living a mediocre life
you're trying but you're really just
going through the motions
you're an earnest person though you
struggle to make genuine connections so
you really don't have any friends
and though you love your parents they
really don't see or appreciate you
you work a meaningless job that you hate
with a boss that hates you you once had
big dreams and even though you still are
a bit naive and foolish in the way that
young people often are you begin to see
that your dreams might not actually be
achievable this is the world you live in
your only real comforts are video games
and your little dog seymour
and then one day suddenly in an instant
you wake up and all of that is gone and
you are brought into a strange and
unfamiliar world
this is the story of the character
philip j fry from the cartoon sci-fi
show futurama
in this video i will explain why
futurama is my favorite cartoon of all
time why i think it has some of the
greatest sci-fi protagonist ever and why
i think every fan of science fiction
should give this show a try keep in mind
this video will have some spoilers i
can't actually talk about what makes the
show great without giving some actual
details about what happens so if hearing
spoilers is something that makes you
lose interest in watching something then
probably don't watch this
futurama begins when philip j fry after
being accidentally frozen awakes in the
year three thousand one thousand years
in the future in the city of new new
york the city was built on top of the
original new york which had been
destroyed by alien invaders the original
new york which was accessible still
through the sewers was inhabited by an
entire society of mutants presumably
deformed by waste dumped into the sewers
by people who lived on the surface
by the year 3000 earth has a whole one
world government and space travel at
incredible speeds is possible
because of faster than light space
travel humankind has made contact with
countless alien species many of which
inhabit the earth and integrate into
society without a problem oftentimes
aliens and futurama are used to
represent certain groups of people in
the real world this concept is also
found in shows like star trek which
futurama constantly references though
we'll get to that
earth is also inhabited by millions of
sentient robots who have lives and jobs
of their own robots in the series are
also sometimes used to represent the
working class though individual robots
do inhabit a number of different roles
in society from actors to sex workers to
gangsters to psychiatrists plenty of
humans have also elected to live
off-world mars is habitable and there
are some that even live on the moon
there are also countless other humans
that live and or work on planetary
colonies or space stations
so we've already been introduced to our
main protagonist philip j fry now let's
move on to our other characters there's
leela who at the beginning of the series
knows nothing about her true homeworld
or of her parents leela is a character
that desperately wants to integrate into
society but has difficulty due to her
insecurities relating to her appearance
she is mostly human looking except for
the fact that she is one large eye she's
the only one of her species on the
planet earth due to the fact that she
was abandoned on the world as a baby
leela and fry have in common that they
are both deeply alone
binder is also one of the show's main
characters he's a sentient alcoholic
amoralistic robot bender and fry
basically have a best friend buddy
relationship throughout the series
then you have professor farnsworth he is
fry's last living relative in the year
3000 his nephew in fact the professor is
a kooky scientist who also owns an
intergalactic shipping company called
planet express
other side characters include zoidberg
and alien lobster who's also an
incompetent medical doctor amy wong a
rich intern from the planet mars and
hermes a bureaucrat who is also co-owner
of planet express
each of these characters receives
central episodes at some point in the
series and these episodes work to
develop the characters backstories and
help us get to know them more so
essentially the gist of the show is the
crew of the planet express ship captain
leela frye and bender are tasked with
delivering packages to all sorts of
strange places throughout the universe
futurama depicts the voyages of the
planet express ship as they explore the
final frontier they encounter all sorts
of strange new worlds and new
civilizations
as a kid futurama was the show that
ignited my love for science fiction and
even though the show is technically a
comedy it is also in my opinion one of
the best sci-fi shows ever made not only
is the show usually successful at being
a comedy it manages to portray
interesting deep and thematically
complex narratives that quite simply gut
you when you least expect it and here
are some examples
the luck of the freight is a major
character episode for philip j fry his
relationship with his family becomes
much clearer and much more defined in
this episode fry after experiencing a
string of bad luck remembers his
seven-leafed clover which he hid away
before he was accidentally frozen and
woken up in the year 3000
he journeys underground to his old home
in the original new york to find it but
upon searching finds out that it had
been stolen
throughout the episode we are shown
flashbacks of fry's interactions with
his family specifically his older
brother yancey who from frye's
perspective seemed covetous of
everything in his life the seven leaved
clover his ability to play basketball
his ability to dance even his name
philip j fry after discovering a statue
resembling his brother yancey among the
ruins of old new york displaying the
clover and edged with fry's name rather
than yancey's fry comes to the
conclusion that his older brother had
stolen the clover and not only had used
it to become successful in life but had
stolen his name as well
the man depicted in the statue had also
accomplished tries lifelong dream of
becoming the first man on mars
to fry his brother has stolen the life
that he should have lived
the episode goes to a dark place and fry
ends up digging up the grave of who he
considers to be the false philip j fry
after recovering the clover fry makes
the discovery however
written on the gravestone reads
here lies philip j fry
named for his uncle to carry on his
spirit
it hadn't been fry's brother after all
fry had always considered his brother
imitating him as stealing when it was
actually admiration
though fry had journeyed to the year
3000 to everyone else he had simply gone
missing
fry's brother yancey had named his first
son after the brother he admired who
vanished mysteriously one day and gave
him the clover he found amongst fry's
things not because he believed it was
magically lucky but because he knew it
was an item that his brother deeply
cared for
upon the realization of this fry sheds a
tear
he leaves the clover where he found it
the point of this is not whether or not
the clover was actually somehow lucky
the point is that fry assumed that his
brother yancey had hated him and was
probably glad that he had gone missing
but from yancey's perspective he lost
the person he had admired the most in
his life
son
i'm naming you philip j fry in honor of
my little brother
who i miss every day
i love you phillip
and i always will by naming his first
son after his brother and giving him the
clover yancey is attempting to keep a
part of fry alive
he will always see a part of his brother
within his son and because he did in
fact love and admire his brother so much
he'd probably encourage the good
characteristics within his son that
resembled his brother's good
characteristics yancey even kept
phillips drawing from when he was a kid
depicting him on a rocket ship and it's
hung over his son's crib
the episode is basically implying that
this is probably what inspired yancy's
son to become an astronaut in the first
place and to be the first man on mars
truly carrying on fry's spirit the
episode is about how the perspectives we
have as children don't always fully
align with reality and if we could learn
to see things from others perspectives
we could spare ourselves a lot of pain
and anger another episode that i really
love is the episode god fellas after
being shot into outer space due to an
accident
binder finds himself adrift in deep
space with the crew of the planet
express ship never able to catch up with
him
after moving through an asteroid field a
rock inhabited by tiny humanoid
creatures lands on him
the citizens assume that he is god
now loads of serious works of science
fiction have dealt with this idea but
the way in which futurama deals with it
has to be applauded if anything for its
straightforwardness in delivering these
ideas essentially it is the question of
whether or not god deserves worship
binder of course is a character who only
really cares about himself he doesn't
really put anyone before himself
initially binder demands that the small
people bring him booze which leads to
countless of them injured or dead bender
feels guilty about this and attempts to
help the tiny people by performing
miracles but mostly they don't go
correctly either and end up causing even
more damage
eventually bender decides that the best
thing he could do would be not to
interfere but by that point it's too
late
bender's religion has led to a war
between the believers and the
non-believers amongst the tiny people
and that ends up annihilating all of
them
the men
the women and the children look daddy
i'm hugging god
maybe if i hug him real hard he'll save
us
like much in futurama the entire
narrative is played comically while
dealing with a very dark subject matter
i should point out that both the
simpsons and south park did similar
episodes but neither of those really
handled the themes in the same way as
futurama especially considering what
happens in the second half of the
episode
after the destruction of the tiny people
civilization
binder is alone floating in the void
while drifting he notices that a nearby
galaxy is signaling out in binary code
he calls out and suddenly speaks to him
the entity claims that it has always
been that it has love for all things
bender asks if that being is god but it
doesn't really give a clear answer and
it doesn't know the direction of earth
binder and the being begin to discuss
the events that occurred with the tiny
people because apparently this being had
been watching
binder remarks that he had tried to help
them but he had had difficulty
determining what was right and what was
wrong to which the being responds
right and wrong are just words what
matters is what you do
i think the episode is basically saying
that sometimes no single moral framework
can be applied to everything
sometimes it is not so easy to determine
the best action
and this is why a man or in bender's
case a robot should never play god
one person cannot determine what is
right and what is wrong for an entire
society of people there is just too much
nuance attempting to play god will only
damage the society more
and this is also as binder learns at the
end of the episode why one should never
put faith in any so-called god to do
anything for you which turned out to be
the lesson that the entity had for him
it is never stated whether or not the
being bender encounters is actually god
probably not just some extremely
powerful ancient being but it does seem
to be a benevolent entity at the very
least
all in all this is definitely one of the
most memorable episodes of futurama and
one that has stuck with me throughout
these years
so now we have to discuss what many
people consider to be the saddest
episode of futurama jurassic bark
as i mentioned earlier fry's only
comforts back in the year 1999 where
video games and his dog seymour
but when fry vanished seymour was left
behind in the early 20th century in new
york
in this episode we learn what happened
to seymour
after discovering seymour's mummified
body in a museum fry convinces them to
return seymour's mummy to him the
professor informs fry that if he wishes
they could make a clone of seymour from
the dna in the fossil
but at the last moment fry stops the
process
he realizes that seymour had lived an
additional 12 years after he had
vanished
perhaps it wasn't right to bring him
back now no matter how much he had
missed him
[Music]
i'll never forget him
but he forgot me a long long time ago
[Music]
however in flashbacks throughout the
episode it is implied that fry is wrong
seymour is seen distressed searching the
city for fry and he's even able to find
him seymour leads fry's parents to his
cryonically frozen body
but even with their missing son's body
right in front of them they still don't
see him this time in the literal sense
seymour tried his best he did everything
a dog could do but still in the end he
could not save his best friend
seymour was forced to leave knowing the
whole time exactly where fry was and not
understanding why he could never come
home
at the end of the episode a time lapse
of seymour waiting for fry is shown as
the dog grows older and older throughout
the seasons
and eventually lays down to die
this is without a doubt the saddest
ending to a cartoon episode ever
and as a kid watching it i definitely
shed a tear and still would
this episode is about the things we
leave behind as we grow and change
it's about the assumptions that we make
to justify it oh i'm sure my middle
school best friend that i never
attempted to contact after we change
schools is doing fine i bet they have a
great life
maybe they don't
maybe they missed you
maybe the absence of you in their life
negatively impacted them
there is a bright side however when
futurama came back on the air after
being cancelled for a few years it is
retconned that a version of fry did go
back to the past and live as seymour's
companion so seymour wasn't alone after
all i know some people don't really like
this and i totally understand why
because it fundamentally changes the
ending of the original seymour episode
however if you use the multiple
universe's view of time travel then that
would mean that fry's original seymour
actually did die alone and the other
version of him got to spend a life with
fry if that makes you any happier i
guess
the episode named a clone of my own
is an episode all about death in a
society where medical science has
reached a level where people can live
indefinitely what happens to the
extremely old when society is done with
them
turns out in the world of futurama where
you turn 160 robots known as the sunset
squad take you away to a mysterious
planet and you're never seen again so
essentially everyone on earth knows when
they are gonna die they know exactly how
much time they have to live barring any
freak accident
in the episode an aging professor
farnsworth growing weary at what he
considers to be his failures and lack of
accomplishments in his life decides to
create a clone of himself to live on in
his name but upon discovering that the
clone doesn't represent who he is
a depressed farnsworth alerts the sunset
squad to come and take him away the
episode involves the planet express crew
going to the near death star
where the robots have placed professor
farnsworth along with endless other
former citizens of earth
into a kind of matrix
the information presented in this
episode about what happens to the old is
one of the many things that exposes the
future of a future as far darker than it
often appears on the surface if you just
glance
in the year 3000 at a certain age all
citizens are assigned a job they do not
get to choose what job they are assigned
some undefined system decides what is
best for them eliminating choice
entirely compliance is necessary anyone
who refuses to do the job assigned is
executed
political candidates are sometimes
literal clones of each other
advertisements are broadcast in their
dreams there are television stations
that literally brainwash you and the
best part of it is most of the dystopian
aspects of futurama are merely
exaggerations of the real world
we in today's society often work jobs
that we hate just to survive political
candidates who are supposed to be on
opposite sides of issues often don't
seem to be that different from their
political opponents once they're elected
we too are inundated with advertisements
everywhere we look and everywhere we go
and television is often full of
brainwashing lies
futurama like all good science fiction
not only is extremely entertaining but
is saying something meaningful about our
society and about the human experience
and it's warning us about certain
problems in our society that might be
exacerbated by technology
futurama is a bright and colorful show
but there's also a deep sadness to it in
the first episode we are introduced to
suicide boosts we can see that there's a
line outside of the suicide booth
indicating there's a high desire for
suicide in the futurama society
this is of course indicative of the fact
that there is a high level of depression
in their society and of course there
would be considering all of the things
that i just mentioned
they don't get to decide their job they
don't really get to decide who leads
them and solas corporations are
constantly using sneaky and unethical
tactics to influence them to buy and
consume things they don't need
in case you haven't realized futurama is
jammed packed with references to science
fiction there's 2001 a space odyssey
there's star wars the work of isaac
asimov twilight zone the planet of the
apes soylent green dune and more than
any other star trek the entire main cast
of the original star trek even showed up
for an episode futurama is a show made
by sci-fi fans for sci-fi fans and it
definitely paved the way for shows like
rick and morty if it hadn't been for
this show i would have never become the
sci-fi fan that i am this channel would
not exist as it is today this show
because of its constant retro sci-fi
references was extremely important for
me and developing a taste for classic
sci-fi and all sci-fi in general you
really grow to love the main cast of the
show as well even zoidberg and the voice
actors really do a great job with all of
these characters futurama will always
have a place in my heart as my most
beloved sci-fi cartoon and i hope this
video helps you understand why
what's your favorite episode of futurama
let me know in the comments
you